de salida brandon debe resolver los
problemas del 45 al 75 esta noche sí
brandon resuelve todos los problemas que
le fueron asignados cuántos problemas
resolverá
entonces existe la curiosidad de
preguntarnos cuánto es 75 menos 45 en
este caso es igual a 30 así que tal vez
brandon resolver a 30 problemas pero hay
que tener mucho cuidado de cómo contamos
las cosas y para verlo mejor vamos a
hacer un ejemplo más chiquito
así que digamos que en vez de hacer
problemas del 45 al 75 hablando le
dejaron hacer el problema del 3 al 6
si utilizáramos la misma técnica de
conteo que acá arriba diríamos bueno si
le dejaron del 3 al 6 tal vez él tenga
que hacer 6 menos 3 problemas en este
caso tendría que resolver tres problemas
vamos a contarlos
1 2 3 4 5 6 si él va a ser los problemas
del 3 al 6 va a resolver
empezando por el 3 el 3 el 4 el 5 y el 6
en realidad él está resolviendo cuatro
problemas
y lo que pasa es que con este método de
sustraer 6-3 nos estamos olvidando del
primer problema solo estamos contando
los siguientes por lo tanto si sus
traemos así debemos aumentar 1 sería 6
menos tres más uno tres más uno
por lo que el número de problemas que
brandon resuelve cuando hace del 45 al
75 es 30
+ 1
vamos a resolver otro problema de
contexto un coladero tiene una baguette
cuantos cortes debe hacer en la baguette
para obtener exactamente siete rebanadas
iguales
podríamos trabajar con el número 7 y
pensar que se deben hacer 7 cortes sin
embargo vamos a hacer un ejemplo más
corto
si se tiene una baguette
y se desea obtener exactamente dos
rebanadas iguales
cuantos cortes se deben hacer
pues solo uno entonces para obtener dos
rebanadas de la baguette se debe hacer
un corte
si se tiene la misma baguette pero ahora
se desea cortar en tres rebanadas
cuantos cortes se deberán hacer
y tenemos uno y dos cortes entonces para
tener la vaca entre rebanadas se deben
hacer dos cortes y creo que se está
viendo un patrón
si tenemos la misma baguette y queremos
cuatro rebanadas iguales de ella
cuantos cortes se deben hacer tendríamos
1 2 3 para tener cuatro rebanadas se
hacen tres cortes
así podríamos seguir nos hasta obtener
en la baguette siete rebanadas iguales
pero se está viendo un patrón el número
de rebanadas que queramos obtener de la
baguette -1 es el número de cortes que
debemos hacer por lo tanto si queremos
obtener siete rebanadas iguales debemos
hacer siete menos uno o sea igual a seis
cortez
vamos al problema y ya está construyendo
una reja con postes separados por una
distancia de un metro cada uno si las
rejas de 18 metros de largo cuántos
postes necesitará así que resolvamos lo
de la misma forma que los otros primero
hagamos un problema más chico si
quisiéramos una reja de 2 metros
necesitaríamos
un poste inicial
un metro de reja
el poste de en medio
un metro de reja ya están los dos metros
y el poste final si comparamos esto con
el problema de las rebanadas tendríamos
una rebanada pero además nos falta el
poste inicial y el poste final si
quisiéramos una reja de tres metros
primero tendríamos el poste inicial
luego un metro de reja
y el otro poste para incrementar otro
metro de ovejas
otro poste
para otro metros de reja final y todavía
no terminamos porque falta el poste
final
si nos damos cuenta aquí necesitamos un
poste al inicio de cada metro de reja y
además el poste final por lo que para
una reja de 3 metros necesitamos cuatro
postes eso quiere decir que si la reja
que está construyendo visión es de 18
metros él necesita 19 postes para
construir la red